it's hard to say that being a teenager
is easy anywhere in the world
but in these streets being a teenager
it's a tough dance between life and
death
like diems how about our city circus
they're hauling it from delito el
salvador is one of the most violent
countries in the world with a homicide
rate about three times as high as
Chicago's most of the killings are
gang-related
there are small clicks everywhere but
the biggest and most deadly gangs bad
real dicey Ocho and Mara Salvatrucha
have been at war for decades they fight
over territory to control drug
trafficking and extortion and they
recruit young people aggressively
this is everybody's holiness commit this
is comienza of the girl corners muchacha
kill 20 euros Lauren como Paul says is a
sacred maravilla kekova Catherine Rose
my olives yeah pair of Celia Costa in my
cell that is OpenBSD under is externally
we don't mean your case yet they watch
one Eugenia so knowing me and her
friends chose a different path in life
they are members of the Salvation
commando a team run emergency response
unit the doubles as a prevention program
to keep kids out of gangs
Noemi started coming to the commandos
with her father when she was 9 years old
her father was also volunteer the
colossian is city anatomica no senate
prácticamente well happy birthday again
oh yes everyone assumed fic know your
composition surrender a number and
commander Java siento
where's cover whatever volunteers
receive training in a wide range of
skills like CPR emergency medical
response live garden vehicle extractions
and search and rescue but most of what
they learn is on the job the skills that
they need to work in the streets of San
Salvador are beyond what anyone can
learn in the classroom
Maria is 18 years old and runs an
ambulance unit
when you fizzle and it's again a pencil
for an open-ocean sorry I'm gonna suffer
Bellavia to carries are you laughs I
brought him over atomic any protein here
to caliper sunako-sama how to contain
two gang members often threatened the
response units when they show up to help
sometimes even welcoming at gunpoint
when the why I never had a proper term
in my scare memento circumstance yeah
well okay i satisfy sarah me pepper day
I even owned a personal
no no value you know what
yeah how you got those almost said
Manohar it's okay I pursue my face XK
medicine que otra persona born in the
highway these volunteers may escape
being involved in gangs
but the witness violence everything on
the job hotel tiempo jessamy soca moon
is a common word yellow to move beyond a
lotta mekomo algo extraño que la
Tourneau comer algo como que la sierra
the area meant each shift starts with a
prayer for safety and strength
[Music]
tenemos que no Tila lavendish yonder
consider knows al contigo una misión
kmu Sabra Sado y que lo hace mope or
don't area men taken todo el amor para
poder completo con ESO la virgen del
commando de algo muy lindo que tiene muy
grande significado para todo lo que
somos c'mon
[Music]
The Salvation commandos started in 1961
it now has 2500 volunteers and 30 posts
throughout the country volunteers join
as young as 14 years of age some of the
group's funding comes from the
government but most of it is from
Norwegians people's aid organization so
la salida de la ciudad I converted my
una gran gran doctora
solo area prefer our regresar my eyes
and I you shall be rocky angry Pais
[Music]